now speaking of doctors i have to get to
the most pressing issue of the day
this was went viral over the weekend and
you know since i fancy myself
a doctor for everybody i i need to take
it up
there was a very delightful and funny
article in the wall street journal by
this guy joseph epstein
no relation to jeffrey as far as i can
tell called
is there a doctor in the white house not
if you need an
md and the article says that joe biden
should think about dropping the
honorific which feels fraudulent
even comic begins madame first lady
misses by
jill kiddo a bit of advice on what may
seem like a small but i think
is not an unimportant matter any chance
you might drop the doctor before your
name
dr joe biden sounds and feels fraudulent
not to say a touch comic
your degree is i believe an ed d
doctor of education earned at the
university of delaware through a
dissertation with the
unpromising title student retention at
the community college level meeting
students needs
wise man once said that no one should
call himself doctor unless he has
delivered a child think about it dr jill
and forth with
drop the doc there is some confusion
here a lot of people especially on the
left think that jill biden
is a medical doctor uh whoopi goldberg
famously infamously
humiliated herself on the view pushing
the idea that jill biden
should be the surgeon general of the
united states i'm hoping dr
jill becomes a surgeon general
yeah joe biden's wife because she's you
know he would never do it but she
yeah she's a hell of a doctor she's an
amazing doctor she's a doctor
she's a teacher but you know might might
be good for betsy devos's post
oh that's so embarrassing that's because
in whoopi's defense whoopi says it she
should be the surgeon general and all of
those
flapping seals in the audience say yo
yes yes give us more
give us more of this sort of nonsense
not not one of those people in the
audience who was clapping and cheering
for that
nor did whoopi goldberg for that matter
know what
dr jill biden had expertise in
and it's not even their fault we live in
a culture that worships at the altar of
scientific expertise
even when that scientific expertise is
rather silly
or seems a little pretentious now i
actually disagree
with the thesis in this article from the
journal even though it's extremely funny
so i still recommend you read the
article
i the word doctor does literally mean
teacher
so i actually i'm sort of i've had this
debate with ben for many years which is
that i think physicians should not use
the term
doctor because they're not doc they're
not teachers usually they're
they're professionals practicing this
this craft i sort of think that only
like
that preschool teachers have more of a
right to use the term doctor than
physicians do neither here nor there
it's a little bit of a pedantic point
i certainly would agree that it is
silly and pretentious to add this title
doctor if you are jill biden
because you heard in that clip i think
it was behar says
well no i'm pretty sure she has a phd
joe biden doesn't have a phd either
phd is a a research focused degree
usually for university professors who
are pursuing
research in in their field she has
what's called an ed
d this is a professional degree usually
for like
high school and middle school
administrators and it just you know
gives
gives you a little bit of a pay bump and
uh then you can style yourself doctor
i am not uh making fun of people who
pursue these degrees it's a more
advanced degree than i have
i being a bachelor perhaps i should
style myself bachelor michael knowles
sweet little elise would very be very
upset with that
i'm making the point that
to style yourself in this way with a
degree
that would maybe appear to
present you with a more rigorous
education than perhaps you have
is really silly during my entire time in
college
i had exactly one professor who
referred to himself as doctor he was
by far the least impressive academic i
studied with
in college he was by far the most
insecure
and he didn't last very long at the
university all the other teachers went
by
professor or they went by
their first name some many of them went
by their first name
if you got it if you really got it if
you're really confident if you're really
shooting on all cylinders
you don't need to flatter yourself with
these sorts of titles i can't tell you
how many
sort of mediocrities i know have been
posting all over the internet say darn
it i earned my degree i deserve it i
studied gender studies or sociology or
whatever
12 years and i deserve to be called this
it's so pathetic a little humility goes
a long way folks even if you really did
look
i'm a strong defender of the humanities
i frankly i don't really care that much
about the hard sciences
i think conservatives have fetishized
the hard sciences and we shouldn't
because i think a lot of these eggheads
don't know anything and they
they as we were discussing earlier
force on us they slip in all sorts of
religious and philosophical and
political stupid premises
underneath the guise of scientific
expertise and i think that
our idolization of the
hard hard sciences and all these sorts
of things has actually led us to become
politically much less sophisticated so i
forget that i actually i
want to talk to the person with the
sociology degree but just don't be so
pompous about it don't be so prideful
about it just
if you really got it let your work speak
for itself
you